morning hey guys uh so you know I I just
listen to that and have a good sense of
been following the tweets and I think we
can probably all weirdly agree that at
some level this is a pretty stupid
conference right because if you think
about it the thought of having a
conference to like push the envelope of
getting everybody to think about mobile
as an important place to do things is
ludicrous right the I mean for anybody
to not understand that it's the closest
thing to the extension of a human being
right like for anybody to even debate
that everything you know we're now 20
years into the current state of the
internet right you know like it's been
20 years since windows 95 came out and
normal people non nerds went on the
platform and so we now have the luxury
of recognizing that all these things
just repeat themselves like everybody
thinks I like I know some of you know me
and some don't but I have a built a
large wine business mainly on web one
point o dynamics right you know 1996
ecommerce site email marketing banner
google adwords and then social kind of
came along which you know for a lot of
us we remember was really just called
web two point oh and they just changed
the word right and so these things came
along and then all the dynamics you know
everyone's like oh you're so good at
social media I'm like right because it's
just like email marketing it's just like
direct mail it's just like the same
thing meaning even this company which I
was an angel investor in button the
theory was we did this for desktop we're
just going to do it for app culture it's
I'm just curious I almost want to turn
this into a weird QA instead of a talk
I'm just curious if this is even a
worthwhile conversation isn't this a
complete foregone conclusion I almost
feel like I'm going to start a
conference called oxygen con oxygen
matters of course it matters like there
is nothing else like like there is no
other ecosystem that's going to matter
in the business world this is where the
money is going to be this is where the
action is this is the first second
I run a 600 person digital social
advertising agency right now and you
know there's a lot of terminology like
the first screen the second screen a lot
of people refer to this as a second
screen because I guess the TV's supposed
to be the first screen this is the first
second third fourth fifth and sixth
screen right I dropped my phone the
other day and my glass cracked and so I
wanted to get it changed an apple said
cool you can get a change come to the
[ __ ] genius bar I go I get there I'm
supposed to get it back in two hours I
said oh weird we have to give it to you
tomorrow morning I literally ran home
and walked around with my laptop because
I couldn't not be connected like
literally everywhere like outside took
my kids to Central Park holding my
laptop because i need to get my text
messages in that place i mean the
thought the debate that this even needs
to be talked about or like there's no
conference that addresses this maybe not
in the most narrow sense but every
conference addresses it like what do we
talk about when we talk about consumer
behavior and what people are happening
everything it only comes from mobile app
culture I don't know and then the
commerce part maybe I'll just share
something that might be interesting I
sorta day I still in my family wine
business I haven't really been involved
with it that much but recently in the
last year I've gotten a little bit more
involved and I I started an Instagram
account called wine deals so real
quickly I be awesome if you guys would
follow that account and so wine deals is
an account that we created mainly to
just sell wine at a ridiculously low
price and free shipping on bottle number
one there was a lot of innovation in the
wine space that followed the group on
living social model of deal the day kind
of dynamics and I felt that Instagram
had an opportunity to become the next
arbitrage of that same exact behavior
aka the same stuff just works everywhere
else you just have to deploy it and make
it contextual to the reality of that
marketplace as many of you guys know in
Instagram because of the functionality
people tag their friends all day long in
the comments which creates enormous
awareness because Instagram right now is
dominating the attention graph which oh
by the way is the only [ __ ] thing
that matters always and forever
it's about attention you reverse
engineer it that's where the money is
that's why all this [ __ ] that we'll talk
about today is going to work because all
our attention is directly transposed in
here 24 7 365 and that's why it's going
to work and then people figure out how
to make it work in that environment so
Instagram which owns the attention graph
in a social environment because I can
have 1 million Twitter followers and
tweet something and 58 things will
happen i can have 150,000 followers on
instagram and four thousand things will
happen that's attention that's a [ __ ]
that matters ninety percent of the
market cares about with because they're
[ __ ] stupid it's all about depth
that's where you actually make things
happen and so you should check out at
wine deals because here's what's
interesting as everybody is trying to
figure out what's the ROI and how do you
make this happen commerce in mobile is
so phenomenal that the execution of wine
deals right now is such horseshit it
makes me so embarrassed that I'm
associated with it right because it's
Instagram you put a [ __ ] picture you
can't link out if you're not running an
ad so literally you push a picture of a
bottle of wine you give the information
there's a discount code in the [ __ ]
post because Wine Library com is a piece
of [ __ ] because I haven't paid attention
to it in a while and so you see that and
then the link out is actually in your
profile because that's the only way you
can lick it out you link it out it sends
you to the current offer it's a complete
disaster show there's nothing good the
level of friction is so insane you get
like burn on your thumb for even being
involved right yet with all that we sell
a fuckload of wine through it because
commerce and mobile is a foregone
conclusion because commerce happens
wherever attention is and that's what
this whole thing is about that's what
it's about it's as simple as that the
only asset that matters to everybody in
this world is broken down in the
following order number one you care
about your family and the people you
love number two you care about money
right and number three and this has been
the most interesting one I'll tell you a
story about it that will contextualize
my whole thesis on what matters here
number three is time time has become
outrageously important to all of us
because we live in a 24-7
65 world now and so one of the big
mistakes in my investment career is I
passed on the angel round of uber twice
which really hurts and and the reason I
invested in the next round was because
my brother AJ took the first uber in New
York City when Travis came he said hey
can you guys test this out so AJ takes
the uber we're sitting in our office it
takes to burr he goes inside and I'd
used uber in San Francisco at this point
but there's just something about it
working out in New York where we have
the greatest transportation of all time
and one hundredth of a second before you
know AJ takes the uber were in the
office still just jamming on what we had
a jam on it he goes downstairs and it
just clicked to me because it was just
so in my face in real life that uber
doesn't sell transportation uber sells
us time right and so the reason all this
infrastructure matters in a nap culture
is it's just seamless there's less
friction that a hundred and thirty
second matters those two seconds matter
right this is really the most important
part of all this what matters when you
start integrating these pumps these
pipes excuse me and let these apps speak
together is just it brings us value and
it brings us value in the place where it
really matters to us which is time and
time is the asset it's why I'm so
passionate about advertising because
advertising for 60 years has done the
opposite it's taken away time from you
right you want to read this article you
turn the page there's a big [ __ ] car
ad that you know second you should not
bother you as much you wanted to watch
happy days because you like the [ __ ]
Fonz you're watching it they stop you
they try to sell you cereal right and
that we just got used to that then all
of sudden DVR came right now we have
adblock incoming it's just that game
right time is the asset that is why
mobile one hundred percent will win let
me ask you guys a quick question let's
just fix it up for a second show of
hands by the way lying is the devil and
to please don't be lazy like I [ __ ]
hate when i asked show of hands and
people head nod it's super basic show of
hands ready show of hands how many
people in this room now actually get
pissed off
when another human being calls them
raise your hand raise it high just hold
it for a second people in front row on
what you look at what I'm looking at
just look at this just hold it high 75
to 80 percent of this room is actually
now mad when another human being calls
them and it's based on one thing which
is when I asked this question three
years ago this room would have raised
their hand at a ten to fifteen percent
clip I've watched this number explode
over the last 36 months the reason that
is is because you value time so much you
are so angry at your best friend or your
mom for calling you because you
recognize that person is hitting you up
on your time that they're stealing your
time that you now have technology where
they should have texted you or emailed
you and you'll get back to them when
you've got the time it is the asset
everything that will play out amongst
this mobile execution app ecosystem is
predicated on that everything and that
is the opportunity at hand that is why
this is going to work and it's the
combination of our disproportionate
enormous value in time and the fact that
this is the place where all of our
attention is one plus one equals three
there's nothing else everything else to
everybody talks about is just minor
details in the scheme event and what you
need to be reverse engineering and
thinking about and strategizing in this
room for whatever the [ __ ] you want to
happen is predicated on those two
pillars period end of story thank you
how much time two minutes five nice I'd
like to do QA because that was really Oh
two examples of companies doing it right
in time or two snapchats winning
attention right let's talk about
snapchat everyone's like why did this is
where sucks is so much smarter than
everybody else he always has for the
last seven years run his company
predicated on attention arbitrage it's
why I bought Instagram when for pride
after 500 days for a billion dollars I
grew [ __ ] stole it we all know it
right now right when he offered three
billion for [ __ ] snapchat everyone's
like what the [ __ ]
he's gonna steal this could you imagine
if we were sitting in a world right this
second we're facebook on Facebook
Instagram and snapchat they would
literally own the entire ecosystem of
attention for the next 10 years and
layer facebook data on top of that
attention and literally be the entire
advertising industry in 10 years like
scary [ __ ] so snapchats winning
attention for all the things they're not
doing right for all the things they
haven't done yet they have attention a
hundred and twenty million [ __ ]
people every day live in that [ __ ]
thing you know and so when everyone's
like what's the business model what I
think you can figure that out eventually
especially when you're raising a good
rilian dollars at a 16 billion dollar
valuation so I so I think snapchat is
stunningly winning the attention raft
they literally are the entire they're
not MTV for thirteen to twenty two year
olds in this generation there the entire
cable industry for thirteen to twenty
two year olds do you know what a
sixteen-year-old girl in Kansas does she
gets home at five pm and she lays in bed
looking at her phone for seven [ __ ]
hours like like I don't know if I'm
flabbergasted at people debating things
this is so obvious is it like and and
the other thing that's most interesting
to me how about this question sorry
Robert I'm giving you only one example
cuz I'm curious about this question how
many people in this room are willing to
right now instill this device into their
body I mean it Oh Keir who here with no
[ __ ] with no [ __ ] like I get
being scared of cancer another random
[ __ ] who here is truly willing to
install a phone not just raising your
hand for shock value who really right
now if given the option would instill a
phone into their forearm or some other
place raise your hand just curious
actually stand up do me a favor i need
the visual please seriously please and
i'm doing this for us as a collective
like legit huh i mean like stay for a
second it's good for blood flow stay for
a second rabbit
this is interesting as [ __ ] like these
are [ __ ] human beings that want to
put a [ __ ] phone in her body thank
you can sit and and here's what's scary
I think for everybody for everybody
that's sitting here there is nobody
that's not confused that at that
percentage of this overall room that is
a one hundred one hundred percent bucket
on one hundred percent indicator that
this is this this is the beginning of us
becoming robots this is the true
extension of our lives shut up Siri this
is the true this is the true extension
of us as human beings how many people
here within every 24 hour period
including when they're sleeping are
always arm's length from their phone
raise your hand thank you